phoenix vor ort
[Musik]
der antrag heißt völkerrecht einhalten
atom abkommen mit dem iran beibehalten
und wir sagen ganz klar wir fordern die
bundesregierung auf an dem atom abkommen
bei zu halten denn die einseitige
aufkündigung des atom abgabe durch
standard trump hat den nahen osten in
eine große gefahr gebracht ein atomares
wettrüsten kann dort womöglich begehen
und hier ist jetzt europa gefragt hier
ist die bundesregierung gefragt klar zu
agieren und anti atom abkommen weiterhin
festzuhalten
also liebe genossinnen und genossen im
prinzip alles gesagt aber es gibt
natürlich auch um das symbol dass es
vernünftig es geht wieder aufwärts
das wichtige ist das richtige signal ist
dass es dinge gibt wo die linke in
großer konsequenz und geschlossen ist
und dazu gehört die friedensfrage liebe
genossinnen und genossen und wir werden
überall ob im deutschen bundestag in der
partei oder wo auch immer dafür kämpfen
dass frieden erhalten bleibt dass kriege
aufhören
das war ein seltener moment bei diesem
linken-parteitag hier in leipzig als ich
gestern partei und fraktionsspitze auf
einem bild zu einem bild eingefunden
haben gut zu einem thema wo es relativ
wenig streit und diskussionen und
debatten gibt nämlich hier
beispielsweise zur friedenspolitik und
zum atom abkommen mit dem iran da muss
man nicht lange diskutieren
da ziehen wir alle an einem strang das
gilt nicht für alle themen und das hat
sich auch wenn die ruhe jetzt hinter mir
trug erst vor einer guten halben stunde
ganz besonders deutlich gezeigt hier wie
gesagt im congress center in leipzig am
dritten und letzten tag des linken
parteitags damit herzlich willkommen
meine damen und herren schön dass sie
wieder mit dabei sind wir wollen ein
klein wenig ganz kurz zurückschauen auf
die vergangenen tage da hat es die
wahlen gegeben zum parteivorsitz wissen
es gab deutliche dämpfer für die beiden
parteivorsitzenden kipping und riexinger
der bundesgeschäftsführer jörg schindler
ist ich sage es mal so mit ach und krach
gewählt worden nämlich erst in der
stichwahl und mit nur drei stimmen
vorsprung und auch was sie den zentralen
antrag des parteivorstandes angeht der
sich hier für offene grenzen und einen
weitgehenden liberale
einwanderungspolitik ausgesprochen hat
auch das kann man durchaus als dämpfer
begreifen und zwar für die position von
sahra wagenknecht und anderen deren
auftritt ist heute mit großer spannung
erwartet worden hier bei diesem
parteitag dann hat es ihn auch gegeben
um kurz nach zwölf ist sie ans
rednerpult gegangen und was sich danach
abgespielt hat das war noch ein klein
wenig spannender all das zeigen wir
ihnen jetzt in den nächsten mindestens
60 minuten und wir beginnen mit der rede
von sahra wagenknecht
[Musik]
liebe genossinnen und genossen
parteitage sind dazu da um über die
arbeit der vergangenheit zu sprechen und
sich über die aufgaben der zukunft zu
verständigen
wir haben bei der bundestagswahl eine
halbe million stimmen dazu gewonnen und
ich finde das war unter den gegebenen
bedingungen überhaupt nicht
selbstverständlich und deswegen möchte
ich mich als allererstes bei allen
mitgliedern bei euch allen dafür
bedanken dass wir so engagiert so aktiv
zu diesem wahlkampf beigetragen habe nur
dank euch haben wir dieses gute
ergebnisse bekommen und ich denke das
war wichtig und das war toll
das wahlergebnis das wahlergebnis
formuliert aber auch unsere wichtigste
aufgabe für die zukunft mit der afg ist
eine rechtsnationale in teilen
faschistische parteien ins parlament
eingezogen die inzwischen offensiv daran
arbeite die deutsche geschichte
umzuschreiben die verbrechen der hitler
diktatur zu relativieren und er ist
immer besser gelingt die themen der
gesellschaftlichen debatte zu bestimmen
und ich finde hier zeigt sich die
wichtigste aufgabe linker polparteien
wir müssen den vormarsch der rechten
stoppen und wir müssen die demokratie
gegen einen entfesselten kapitalismus
und eine zunehmend autoritär ismus
verteidigen das ist doch unsere zentrale
aufgabe wir sollten darüber reden wie
wir das am besten schaffen und wir
müssen
wir müssen denke ich auch immer wieder
darauf hinweisen dass das zwei seiten
einer medaille sind die afc ist doch
nicht das gegenprogramm zu merkel
die afd ist doch das produkt von merkel
sie ist doch das produkt von merkels
marktkonforme demokratie wo die
konzernchefs den kurs bestimmen und wo
die große mehrheit für eine stimme mehr
hat und auch die verrohung und sprache
und denken die sich in den harz
kommentaren bei facebook aus tote und
über die sich die neoliberalen eliten so
gern in vornehmem abscheu erheben diese
verrohung von sprache und denken das ist
doch das ergebnis der form der sozialen
verhältnisse die genau diese
neoliberalen eliten herbeigeführt haben
das ist doch das produkt ihrer politik
und ich denke ich denke die die bahn hat
recht wenn er darauf hinweist dass das
wort ungleichheit eine beschönigung ist
und dass wir es in wahrheit mit nackter
ausbeuterischer gewalt zu tun haben und
diese gewalt die wird millionen menschen
in diesem land tagtäglich angetan
sie wird ihnen angetan in unternehmen wo
der renditedruck inzwischen so groß ist
dass immer mehr mittel genutzt werden
lohndumping zu betreiben über
outsourcing über leiharbeit über
befristungen es wird doch alles genutzt
wenn es darum geht löhne nach unten zu
drücken viele menschen konnten von ihrem
job nur noch so schlecht leben dass sie
einen zweiten brauchen und wer nicht
topfit und gesund ist der hat auf diesem
arbeitsmarkt faktisch keine chance mehr
und das gilt nicht nur für die deutsche
post das sind doch unerträgliche
zustände und das sind zustände die krank
machen und gegen die müssen wir uns
erheben dafür werden wir gebraucht und
dafür sind wir da
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und wenn diese menschen wenn diese
menschen denen die politik der letzten
jahre jede chance auf ein planbares
leben genommen hat wenn sie sich nach
sicherheit sehnen nach stabilität und
nach schutz dann meine ich müssen sie
spüren dass wir an ihrer seite stehen
wir sind doch gegründet worden
wir sind doch gegründet worden um uns
für die einzusetzen für die sonst
niemand kennt und die keine laute stimme
haben
und ich finde wenn wir das als unsere
aufgabe annehmen dann können wir nicht
damit zufrieden sein wo wir heute stehen
natürlich freuen wir uns wenn wir in den
uni-städten wenn wir in den angesagten
vierteln gute ergebnisse erreichen
ich finde es jedes mal spannend wenn ich
in den hörsälen von universitäten mit
1000 studenten diskutieren kann und ich
freue mich über das interesse dass man
dort erlebt dass es großartig dass es
dieses interesse gibt aber wenn wir
gleichzeitig im ruhrgebiet oder in den
abgehängten regionen des ostens das
waren ja mal unsere hochburgen wenn wir
dort an rückhalt verlieren und wenn
ausgerechnet die ihre leben von der
agenda 2010 am schlimmsten verwüstet
wurde uns immer seltener ihre stimme
geben wenn inzwischen mehr
gewerkschafter afd wählen als uns wenn
mehr arbeitslos und arbeiter afd wählen
als uns dann finde ich können wir uns
nicht zurücklehnen und zur tagesordnung
übergehen
[Applaus]
und ich finde
ich finde es zeugt nicht von einer guten
diskussionskultur wenn auf das
ansprechen solcher probleme mit dem
vorwurf reagiert wird
da würde jemand die linke schlecht reden
oder unsere erfolge schmälern
es geht doch nicht darum unsere erfolge
zu schmälern es geht darum dass wir
gemeinsam darüber nachdenken wie wir die
menschen zurückgewinnen die wir in den
letzten jahren verloren haben das ist
doch das thema darum geht es doch
[Applaus]
und ich meine ich meine das wird uns nur
gelingen wenn wir ihre sprache sprechen
wenn sie spüren dass wir ihre probleme
ihre ängste ihre lebensrealität kennen
und dass wir ihnen mit respekt begegnen
und nicht von oben herab
und nur wenn wir das wild nur wenn uns
das gelingt wenn wir die ärmeren die
abstiegsgefährdeten wenn wir sie wieder
erreichen nur dann können wir auch darin
erfolgreich sein und dem rechtsruck
entgegenzustellen nur dann schaffen wir
doch was unsere wichtige aufgabe ist
dann brauchen wir doch diesen rückhalt
und dafür müssen wir uns um diese
menschen bemühen statt sie abzuhaken
oder abzuschreiben nein die ärmeren die
abstiegsgefährdeten die haben noch die
gleichen interessen über die wir kämpfen
und deswegen werden sie gewinnen und
können wir sie gewinnen und das ist
unsere aufgabe
und dabei ist die rechtsentwicklung aber
nicht die einzige herausforderung
wir leben in einer zeit wachsender
kriegsgefahr
vor allem die gefahr einer militärischen
auseinandersetzung zwischen den
atommächten wächst die dreistigkeit mit
der die usa die nahen osten weiter
destabilisieren und die offenheit mit
der einen krieg gegen den iran
vorbereitet wird die sind doch
erschreckend aber bei aller empörung
über trance beleihen und trams lügen
zur wahrheit gehört eben auch
internationale verträge werden nicht
erst seit donald trump gebrochen und das
völkerrecht wird auch nicht erst seit
donald trump mit füßen getreten sondern
das war schon vorher so
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das völkerrecht das völkerrecht wird
doch überall mit füßen getreten wo große
militärmächte sich anmaßen länder deren
regierungen ihnen nicht passen oder die
in ihre rohstoffe nicht zu den
gewünschten konditionen zur verfügung
stellen militärisch zu verwüsten und das
völkerrecht und auch überall mit füßen
getreten wo islamistische terror banden
aufgerüstet werden um unliebsame regime
zu den stabilisieren oder wo mit drohnen
ein brunnen eingesetzt werden um
willkürliche morde per fernsteuerung zu
exekutieren bei all diesen verbrechen
hört das völkerrecht gebrochen und ich
finde statt mit fadenscheinigen
hinweisen auf die krim russlands
wiederaufnahme in den g8 zu
hintertreiben sollte sich merkel lieber
darum kümmern dass das völkerrecht
wieder grundlage der deutschen
außenpolitik wird nur was man selbst
haftet dessen 8 und auch von den anderen
verlangen
aber stattdessen stattdessen ist der
umgang mit russland an heuchelei nicht
zu überbieten da werden anfang des
jahres vier diplomaten ausgewiesen weil
in großbritannien ein mordanschlag mit
einem gift vorgenommen wurde
über das wie wir heute wissen alle
großen geheimdienste dieser welt
verfügen einschließlich des bnd
aber wenn der us-botschafter sich wie
ein neuer kolonialer aufführt und offen
ankündigt dass er in europa die rechte
an die macht bringen will
da wird der von herrn mas und
kaffeeplausch eingeladen
statt ihm ein rückflugticket zu
überreichen washington werde daher die
angemessene reaktion gewesen
[Applaus]
aber diese ganze und
diese ganze politik diese ganze politik
ist nicht nur zutiefst unehrlich sie ist
vor allem extrem gefährlich heute stehen
deutsche truppen an der russischen
grenze
und es werden immer wieder martialische
manöver in osteuropa an abgehalten
die nato gibt jetzt schon 900 milliarden
dollar die zahl es mehrfach genannt
wurden jedes jahr für rüstung aus und
obwohl im vergleich dazu russland mit 66
milliarden dasteht wird weitere
aufrüstung gefordert wird weitere
aufrüstung vorangetrieben und die große
koalition macht munter mit allen
versprechen der spd zum trotz und ich
finde dieser rüstungs wahnsinn
der ist doch auch ein sinnbild für
unsere kranke welt der werden jahr für
jahr 900 milliarden dollar für
mordwerkzeuge ausgegeben ein zehntel
davon würde ausreichen damit auf diesem
planeten kein kind mehr verhungern
müsste oder an armut krankheiten sterben
müsste und dass das nicht möglich ist
das zeigt doch wie kommt diese welt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir wissen
wir wissen dass der kapitalismus den
krieg in sich trägt wie die wolke den
regen und es zeigt sich immer deutlicher
der krise überwinden will ja der muss
eine wirtschaftsordnung überwinden in
der der profit das maß aller dinge ist
und wo die schlimmsten verbrechen
begangen werden wenn sich damit profite
machen lassen
der papst hat doch recht der papst hat
doch recht diese wirtschaft tötet und
wir sind die einzige partei die den
zusammenhang von wirtschaftsordnung und
rohstoff kriegen offenlegt wir sind die
einzige antikriegspartei im deutschen
bundestag und nicht finde
darum sollten wir auch unverändert stolz
sein
[Applaus]
und die vorbereitung
die vorbereitung jedes krieges beginnt
mit waffenlieferungen seit jahren dielen
spd und cdu mit den rüstungslobbyisten
und sie liefe ihnen die waffen den
erdogan und den saudis damit sie ihre
blutigen kriege in syrien oder auch im
jemen führen können und insoweit ist es
eben auch wichtig dieses verbrechen muss
aufhören und ich bin froh dass es mit
der linken wenigstens eine partei gibt
die sich nicht von den
rüstungslobbyisten schmieren es so wie
kauder und co nein das muss endlich zu
ende sein
und liebe genossinnen und genossen liebe
genossinnen und genossen wir sind uns
auch einig es kriege eine hauptursache
weltweiter flucht bewegungen sind und
wir sind uns einig dass erfolg erfolg
der asyl erhalten müssen und ich bin
stolz darauf dass die bundestagsfraktion
gegen jede verschärfung des asylrechts
gestimmt hat und das wird auch so
bleiben und ich finde das zeigt doch
probe in dieser frage stehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und wir sind uns wir sind uns ebenfalls
einig dass kriegsflüchtlingen geholfen
werden muss
es gibt niemanden in der linken der das
in frage stellt und ich finde es zeugt
nicht von gutem stil wenn immer so getan
wird als sei das anders nein das ist
nicht anders
worüber wir diskutieren ist ob eine welt
ohne grenzen und der kapitalistischen
bedingungen wirklich eine linke
forderung sein kann
und selbst da gibt es einiges was
eigentlich gar nicht umstritten ist wir
verteidigen das recht armer länder ihre
märkte ihre wirtschaft mit zöllen gegen
unsere agrarexporte zu verteidigen und
zu schützen das heißt eben aber auch den
freien warenverkehr grenzen zu setzen
wir fordern kapitalverkehrskontrollen um
zu verhindern dass finanzspekulanten
über währungen zinsen und das schicksal
ganzer volkswirtschaften entscheiden
also auch den freien kapitalverkehr
wollen wir natürlich grenzen setzen ja
und viele von uns viele von uns sind
vermutlich der meinung dass es
unverantwortlich ist armen ländern ihre
qualifizierten fachkräfte abzuwerben
weil das armut und elend vor ort nur
weiter vergrößert jahren streiten über
die frage ob es für arbeitsmigration
grenzen geben sollte und wenn ja wo sie
liegen aber warum können wir das nicht
sachlich tun ohne diffamierungen
[Applaus]
auch der linke auch der linke bernie
sanders hat zu diesem thema eine sehr
pointierte meinung zitiere bernie
sanders offene grenzen nein das ist ein
vorschlag der koch brüder das sind
großindustrielle mit 40 milliarden
vermögen
ich zitiere bernie sanders weiter was
die rechte in diesem land liebt ist doch
eine politik der offenen grenzen bringen
jede menge leute die für 2 oder 3 dollar
die stunde arbeiten das wäre toll für
die daran glaube ich nicht
ich glaube wir müssen mit dem rest der
industrieländer zusammenarbeiten um die
weltweite armut anzugehen aber das
gelingt nicht indem wir die menschen in
diesem land ärmer machen so weit
bernie sanders wenn jeremy corbijn sich
zu diesem thema äußert dann klingt das
ähnlich
man muss diese meinung nicht teilen aber
deshalb sind bernie sanders und jeremy
corbijn noch lange keine leute die den
rechten hinterherlaufen und ihre
argumente übernehmen
was ist denn das für eine unkultur der
debatte
[Applaus]
und ich erwarte auch nicht
ich erwarte auch nicht dass alle meine
meinung teilen natürlich nicht aber was
ich erwarte ist eine solidarische
diskussion und wenn mir und anderen
genossinnen und genossen aus den eigenen
reihen nationalismus rassismus oder fdp
vorgeworfen wird oder wenn unterstellt
wird wir würden vor dem rechten zeit das
einknicken dann ist das das gegenteil
einer solidarischen debatte ich meine
beispiel leid
und als die leid war die rede übernahme
von afg position
man muss sich doch mal darüber im klaren
sein was man damit eigentlich sagt damit
rückt man genossen und genossen unsere
partei in die nähe eines alexander
gauland der das verbrecherische nazi
regime als vogelschuss in der deutschen
geschichte bezeichnet hat ich finde das
in form und ich finde das dürfen wir
nicht machen und erträgen
deswegen meine ich
deswegen meine ich wir sollten diese
absurden debatten beenden und lieber
gemeinsam darum kämpfen dass bauland afd
zu einem vogelschießen in der deutschen
geschichte wird nämlich dass die hinten
jahren vergessen sein wird kann es doch
unser job steht uns jetzt so ein
unternehmen und solche kämpfe zu führen
[Applaus]
und ein letzten punkt ein letzten punkt
möchte ich ganz kurz noch ansprechen
ich möchte noch etwas zu dem projekt
einer überparteilichen linken
sammlungsbewegung sagen weil ich finde
dass auch hier teilweise seltsame
debatten geführt werden liebe
genossinnen und genossen es geht doch
nicht um ein alternativprojekt zur
linken das uns schwächen sondern es geht
darum dass wir breiter und stärker
werden wenn wir die politik in diesem
land verändern wollen das ist doch das
anliegen und das ist doch der
hintergrund es kann uns doch nicht
genügen
es kann uns doch nicht genügen wenn wir
bei der nächsten bundestagswahl auch
wenn das schön ist ein oder zwei prozent
mehr haben darum kämpfen wir alle darum
kämpfen wir ja da werde ich will ich mit
euch gemeinsam darum kämpfen vielleicht
auch fünf prozent mehr
und dann fängt bei der nächsten mal noch
mal zwei prozent aber damit sind wir
immer noch von gesellschaft von
politischen mehrheiten weit entfernt und
ich finde wir müssen dieses problem
angehen und wir müssen auch sehen wir
müssen auch sehen
die spd hat in den letzten jahren über
zehn millionen wähler und
hunderttausende mitglieder verloren
wir müssen uns doch fragen warum so
wenige von denen bei uns angekommen sind
das hätte ich mir doch auch anders
gewünscht aber das ist die realität und
deswegen müssen wir darüber nachdenken
ob es nicht wege gibt durch ein
breiteres bündnis diese menschen wieder
zu erreichen aldi zusammenzuführen
die verhöre löhne für bessere renten
unsere friedenspolitik streiten wollen
wir sind doch nicht für uns selbst da
wir wollen doch dieses land verändern
und ich bin überzeugt wir können dieses
land verändern und deshalb lasst uns die
grabenkämpfe beenden lasst uns gemeinsam
daran arbeiten die verhältnisse zu
überwinden
die tagtäglich die wut und den hass
produzieren die den braunen schoss
wieder fruchtbar gemacht haben kämpfen
wir um dieses land ist in deutschlands
und in höchst zu überlassen darum möchte
ich auch mit euch gemeinsam kämpfen das
ist doch unsere aufgabe nehmen wir sie
an und da werden wir auch erfolgreich
sein
vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die lange erwartete rede von sahra
wagenknecht der vorsitzenden der
bundestagsfraktion die so viel und so
oft eine rolle gespielt hat hier bei
diesem parteitag nun hatte sie ihre
position endlich noch einmal hier
ausgeführt und es gab sehr
unterschiedliche reaktionen auf der
einen seite sehr viel applaus in einem
der großen glocke in unter den
delegierten hier auf der anderen seite
aber auch sehr große zurückhaltung und
diese zurückhaltung zu erklären dass
selbst ergab sich unmittelbar nach der
rede dann ganz von alleine als nämlich
die das parteitagspräsidium die
veranstaltung dahingegen fortsetzte dass
sie fragen zu ließ an die rednerin von
eben und dann entwickelte sich eine doch
erstaunliche eigendynamik hier bei
diesem parteitag so schönen dank zara
unsere regularien sehen vor dass bis zu
drei nachfragen gestellt werden können
zu redebeiträgen mir ist eine nachfrage
angekündigt von sabine leidig aber ich
kann nicht sehen wo sie irgendwo ist ja
auf micro vier ja es ist ja ein bisschen
voller minute sabine vielen dank zara
für deine ausführungen
du hast zu recht gesagt dass alle
positionen auch diskutiert werden müssen
auch unsere positionen zu
migrationsfragen
ich möchte dich nun fragen warum dies du
deine position die du bisher über die
medien vertreten hass zu denen ja die
meisten hier gar keinen zugang haben
warum du deine position nicht hier auf
dem parteitag zur debatte gestellt hast
damit wir beschließen
[Applaus]
liebe
ebel sabine es ist okay wenn wir erst
mal die nachfrage sammeln oder willst du
sonst antwortete gleich es gibt de haben
noch keinem nico gesehen also so ganz
kann ich deine frage nicht
nachvollziehen ich habe doch gerade hier
meine position begründet und dargelegt
also ich meine was heißt denn zur
debatte stellen
und ich bin nicht der meinung ich bin
allerdings nicht der meinung dass es
sinnvoll gewesen wäre auf diesem
parteitag in kampfabstimmungen am ende
mit 60 zu 40 für die eine oder andere
position zu entscheiden und ich bin froh
ich bin froh dass der leitantrag einen
kompromiss enthält mit dem alle leben
können die formulierung offene grenzen
für alle ist nicht mehr drin
zur frage der arbeitsmigration steht da
nicht sondern ansonsten stehen lauter
gute und wichtige dinge drin wo wir uns
einig sind luftpolster aachen bekämpfen
soziale offensive solidarität mit
flüchtlingen das ist doch unsere
gemeinsame position und ich möchte dass
wir nur gemeinsam beschließen und uns
nicht zerlegen und deswegen habe ich
hier nicht mit an mit anträgen
polarisiert die am ende diesem partei
dann nur zerlegt hätten das hätte uns
doch alles nichts gebracht also ich
finde das gemeinsame in den vordergrund
zu stellen sachlich über
unterschiedliche meinungen zu
diskutieren das ist das herangehen was
uns weiterbringt und nicht diese art der
debatten die wir vor dem parteitag
teilweise geführt haben mit diffamierung
und anderem
[Applaus]
dass ich jetzt nur 20
dazu einmal micro fia im mikro 64 bit
[Musik]
sarah steilen deine position nicht elke
breitenbach zufällig gerade dadurch dass
du keine debatten zulässt und seit
monaten nicht zulässt
diese partei du ignoriert die position
der mehrheit dieser partei und du hast
jetzt und du hast jetzt genau wieder
nachgelegt und das ist gut glaublich und
ich bin nicht mehr bereit das länger
hinzunehmen und ich erwarte von dir dass
du die position die mehrheitsposition
dieser partei 8 sowie allen positionen
gut machen und ich möchte wissen was
sind für dich geflüchtete du redest von
kriegsflüchtlingen welche anderen
flüchtlinge gibt es denn für dich noch
redest du von wirtschaftsflüchtlingen
jetzt noch eine weitere nachfrage auf
micro 6 dass karadzic bin delegierter
für die aka l nummer 487 sarah du hast
als es ich glaube im letzten jahr
versuchte terroranschläge in deutschland
gab einen zusammenhang zwischen
einwanderung und terroranschlägen
hergestellt ich würde dich fragen ob du
diesen zusammenhang tatsächlich siehst
oder ob du nicht der meinung bist dass
die herstellung eines solchen
zusammenhangs wasser auf die mühlen der
falschen kräfte in dieser republik sind
zweite frage zweite frage ich habe 1992
in bonn gegen die faktische abschaffung
des asylrechts demonstriert und ich
finde es reicht nicht wenn die linke nur
asylrechts verschärfungen zurück weiß
sondern wir müssen für eine deutliche
ausweitung und wiederherstellung des
asylrechts eintreten
teilst du diese position du hast das
wort bitte
also zunächst einmal wir haben immer
auch als bundestagsfraktion das dublin
system kritisiert das ist ja der
hintergrund der damaligen veränderungen
gewesen wir haben immer gesagt es geht
nicht dass gerade die ärmeren
europäischen länder wie griechenland und
italien die hauptlasten tragen da gibt
es überhaupt keine differenz sondern
selbstverständlich sehen wir das eben so
dass das verändert werden muss aber ich
finde trotzdem ist es doch schon mal
eine wichtige frage dass es eine partei
gibt die allen verschärfungen
entgegengestellt sich entgegengestellt
hat das macht uns keiner die grünen
haben gezielt die spd die cdu macht
sowieso mit also wir können auch mal
deutlich festhalten dass hier von uns
eine ganz klare position in der
bundestagsfraktion vertreten wurde
und wir haben natürlich auch immer
wieder anträge eingebracht die auf
konkrete verbesserungen gezielt haben
also da werden wieder künstliche
differenzen auf gemacht die ich
überhaupt nicht sehe
und wo ich mich wirklich gerade wo das
hinführen soll und der zweite punkt
[Musik]
der zweite punkt liebe elke also
natürlich kann man über die frage
diskutieren und das habe ich ja gerade
also ich verhindere doch keine
diskussion also im gegenteil ich wünsche
mir doch sachliche diskussion und ich
versuche mit meinen beiträgen dazu
beizutragen dass wir darüber diskutieren
natürlich ist das ein emotionales thema
ja und trotzdem es gibt auf dieser welt
unendlich viel elend unendlich vielen
not und ich finde wenn wir sachlich
diskutieren müssen wir uns auch darüber
im klaren werden den hungernden in
afrika nützen offene grenzen nichts weil
sie gar nicht die mittel haben weil sie
gar nicht die mittel haben sich auf den
weg zu machen die allerärmsten die alle
ernst in dieser welt brauchen unsere
hilfe für ort und deswegen finde ich
muss die linke dass in den vordergrund
stellen ich meine auch bei den
kriegsflüchtlingen zehn prozent schaffen
es nach europa 90% leben unter elenden
bedingungen vor ort auch in syrien das
hat sich doch bis heute nicht verändert
mein warum haben sich denn fünf 2015 so
viele menschen auf den weg gemacht weil
es eben vor ort unsäglichen bedingungen
darf weil frau merkel und auch die
deutsche regierung die überweisung an
das uhr in hcr gekürzt hat und
entsprechend wurden dort die
lebensmittelrationen gekürzt bis heute
ist es so dass dort keine medizinische
versorgung da ist dass dort keine
bildung da ist und wie gesagt in den
vielen elends gebieten dieser welt leben
millionen menschen und ich möchte den
fokus der debatte darauf richten dass
wir dort helfen müssen das wird da die
außenpolitik verändern müssen wenn
darauf wird dann muss ich sagen kann ist
für mich dann keine soziale
gerechtigkeit mehr wenn das nicht im
fokus unserer debatte steht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so fielen dann
ich sehe jetzt einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag auch nico fünf
bitte ich möchte eine persönliche
erklärung abgeben einnahmen
entschuldigung das geht jetzt nicht
warum es öffentliche erklärung könnte
unserer geschäftsordnung nach
abstimmungen abgeben aber nicht einfach
so du kannst einen antrag zur
geschäftsordnung stellen wenn du
delegierte bis zur teilnehmerin mit
beratender stimme dann müsstest du
deinen namen und deine delegierten
nummer sagen mein name ist es kühl
delegierten nummer 175 und zwar auch
wenn ich keine persönliche erklärung
abgeben da was passiert hier gerade ich
möchte eine frage stellt als kind von
flüchtlings eltern welches in den 90er
jahren hierhin gekommen ist möchte ich
mich ganz herzlich bei sarah bedanken
dafür dass die klientel erreicht die wir
nicht erreichen um genau diesen punkt
züchtiges problematik zu thematisieren
ich finde es unglaublich weniger
menschen als genossen und genossen
bezeichnen und gemeinsam für euch breite
ja dann können wir nicht die vermehrung
deutsch in die rechte ecke bringen wir
tun uns keinen gefallen
ich brauche euch nicht über und dabei so
überzeugen wie braucht mich nicht zu
überzeugen dass wieder menschen helfen
müssen ist aber den menschen bloß
überzeugen und mit dieser art und weise
dieser widerlichen intrigant so jetzt
nicht so lange bis der regen hat er
nicht nur für seinen missbrauch unserer
geschäftsordnung ja bisher haben wir uns
sehr streng an die geschäftsordnung
gehalten
du kannst dich ein
geschäftsordnungsantrag verbinden mit
einer persönlichen erklärung und dann
mit einer beschimpfung eines teils des
publikums später jetzt also wenn es
tatsächlich einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag gibt auf micro
vier zur geschäftsordnung zu sprechen
und danach hat bernd riexinger um ein
kurzes wort gebeten
johannes hefel delegierten nummer 181
ich möchte den parteitag entscheiden
lassen ob wir hier an dieser stelle eine
begrenzte debatte zu genau diesem thema
für sagen wir eine stunde führen das ist
ein antrag zur geschäftsordnung gibt es
eine gegenrede zu diesem antrag wut und
zorn also in beiden lagern wenn man das
so sagen darf bei diesem parteitag hier
der linken und daneben auch ein antrag
zur geschäftsordnung eine zeitlich
begrenzte debatte zuzulassen zu diesem
thema das hat dann auch tatsächlich eine
mehrheit gefunden aber eine mehrheit von
exakt einer stimme und dann ging es ja
noch ein klein wenig weiter mit
geschäftsordnungsanträgen unter anderem
der letzte war dass man eine 15 minütige
unterbrechung dieses parteitags haben
wollte auch das ganz knapp aber das ist
jetzt im moment der stand der dinge und
wenn wir noch mal kurz zurück gucken auf
das was da in den letzten - wir ihnen in
den letzten minuten gezeigt haben
nämlich wie ich schon gesagt habe wut
und zorn und große emotionen unter den
delegierten hier dann mag das unter
anderem auch dem umstand geschuldet sein
dass zum einen das eigentliche problem
um das es sich hier dreht und das sahra
wagenknecht in ihrer rede auch noch mal
aufgenommen hat dass nämlich der punkt
der arbeitsmigration auch im zentralen
antrag des parteivorstands nicht weiter
ausgeführt wird sondern wie man da einen
großen bogen drum gemacht hat dass das
der eine grund dafür sein mag und der
andere natürlich auch der das sahra
wagenknecht weder mit den delegierten
hier diskutiert hat noch auch mit großen
teilen ihrer fraktion in den vergangenen
wochen und monaten sondern vorzugsweise
in interviews über die medien ihre
position verbreiten hat er verbreitet
hat all das hat sich hier vor einer
guten halben stunde entladen und inge
swolek ist unter den delegierten und
frag mal wie die atmosphäre jetzt ist ja
ich bin unter den delegierten und habe
den delegierten gefunden der für diese
turbulenz nach der rede von sahra
wagenknecht verantwortlich ist sie haben
den antrag gestellt damit man diskutiert
warum ich halte es für massiv wichtig
dass wir gerade nach der rede von sahra
wagenknecht jetzt innerhalb der partei
eine diskussion darüber führen wie wir
uns aufstellen wie wir zu offenen
grenzen stehen und auch sarah ein klares
signal geben wo sie mit ihrer meinung
steht jetzt haben sie den antrag
gestellt jetzt gibt es eine debatte aber
nur eine stimme mehr
und sonst jetzt die nicht gegeben
warum ist das so wollen die nicht
diskutieren die linken doch die linken
wollen definitiv diskutieren aber es
gibt eben auch viele strategen in
unserer partei was oftmals gut ist aber
manchmal eben auch schwierig und ich
glaube die strategen dieser partei
halten ist für schwierig diese
diskussion in der öffentlichkeit zu
führen mit begleitung der medien herum
ja weil es sicherlich harte worte geben
wird gegen sarah und sicherlich auch
harte worte für sarah und gegen die
gegner sahra wagenknecht also ist die
partei gar nicht so so einheitlich wie
sie sich präsentiert im tief rein
brodelt doch wir haben ganz klare ziele
in unserem parteiprogramm und ich glaube
viele delegierte hier meinen dass auch
eine sache wagenknecht sich an dieses
parteiprogramm zu erhalten hat und über
ihre medienäußerungen daneben oftmals
verärgert sind weil sie eben ein
falsches bild dieser partei abgeben ob
es tief greifend brodelt in der partei
das glaube ich gar nicht ich glaube wir
sind an vielen punkten sehr geschlossen
[Musik]
ja aber man muss auch nicht sagen dass
wir zerstritten sind wir haben einfach
viele meinungen und die kann man sich
hier gut abbilden und ich glaube dass
viele in unserer partei auch mit
demokratie umgehen können und wenn es
eine antrag gibt und der beschlossen
wird dann ist das so und dann ordnen
sich die die gegen den antrag waren eben
auch unter und das erwarte ich dann eben
auch von einer sahra wagenknecht wenn
wir uns für offene grenzen aussprechen
dass sie sich dann auch diese an diese
parteitagsbeschlüsse hält während ihrer
rede konnte ich gut beobachten rechts
wird platt da sitzen die lässt verbände
links mit weniger klatscht die aus
verbände sind das die lage
also die lager kann man an den klatschen
schon durchaus gut erkennen
im westen gibt es dir die wagenknecht
fans und ich sag mal im osten wird das
was ich mitbekomme sarah auch eher
kritisch gesehen
die sammelbewegung die sie da jetzt
startete im september hat sie das falsch
kommuniziert definitiv das ist genau das
problem was sahra wagenknecht hat sie
setzt sich oftmals für sagt auch in
ihrer rede sie möchte einen diskurs
führen aber die mitglieder erfahren von
ihren meinungen und ihren statements
immer nur aus der presse
und ich kann mich an ein landesparteitag
in thüringen erinnern wo sie 20 minuten
geredet hat und sofort weg war und damit
eben auch ein diskurs über damals gegen
die debatte zu asylrecht gastrecht diese
debatte dann überhaupt nicht geführt
werden konnte und das ist ein problem in
dieser debatte muss sie sich jetzt eben
stellen das finde ich gut
vielen dank die hälfte jetzt beginnt die
debatte die sie gefordert haben nämlich
an wollen sie auch mitmachen und bei uns
geht es ja weiter mit dieser net klage
erfolgreich tagungsleitung die im moment
hier bei benjamin immanuel hoff liegt
die bittet jetzt die delegierten noch
sich hinzusetzen damit man hier wirklich
zu diese antrag der begrenzten debatte
aber entkommen kann man jetzt wird es
noch einige verfahren muss vorschläge
und hinweise geben
hört mal rein hat es gibt hinweise aus
dem saal die uns erreicht haben als
tagungs präsidium das ist eine ganze
reihe von akteuren gibt die sich zu wort
gemeldet haben die gesagt haben erstens
für mich ist das eine blöde situation
mich hier an dieses mikrofone vorne zu
stellen außerdem geht es vom ablauf her
schneller wenn die leute wenn wir einen
für die weiblichen
delegierten haben und einen für die
männlichen delegierten die jetzt der
reihe nach aufgerufen werden und dass
man das vom saal mikrofon ausmacht das
erleichtert auch sozusagen diesen hoch
und runter gehe ablauf deshalb würden
wir sagen das mikrofon 1 hier vorne ist
das mikrofon an dem sich die rednerinnen
auf der in das mikrofon 24 vorne ist das
ist das mikrofon an dem die redner das
wort ergreifen
wir haben jetzt eine ganze reihe von
wortmeldungen die abgegeben worden sind
und ich würde jetzt die beiden ersten
nennen die auf der rednerliste stehen
und dann sagen wie er sich vorbereitet
und möchte dann bitten dass sie
akteurinnen und akteure auch bitte am
seil mit sicherheit auch die schnelle
aussortieren weil diese antrag hierzu
dieser begrenzen bietet er kann er
wirklich sehr überraschend in der tat
und sie haben ja auch die parteispitze
gemeinsamen gespräch gesehen mit sahra
wagenknecht und dietmar bartsch und das
wird es natürlich darum gehen wie äußern
sich hier die führenden personen zu
dieser auseinandersetzung zu dir sehr
sehr aufgeheizten atmosphäre sahra
wagenknecht gegründet die hatte ich hier
am rande geäußert es wäre gut gewesen
hat sie gesagt wenn sich die
parteivorsitzenden nach dem antrag zu
dieser begrenzen debatte zu wort
gemeldet hätten und von einer debatte in
einer derart aufgeheizten atmosphäre
angeraten
es war ja auch das denkbar knappe votum
mit nur einer stimme wie gesagt da hat
sich ja die mehrheit der delegierten
entschieden
doch wir brauchen jetzt darüber
diskutieren wir wollen darüber
diskutieren was uns in den letzten monat
man auseinandersetzungen gab und was die
partei zu klären hat mikrofon 2 enrico
rossi
sofern enrico nicht an rede
enrico wo bist du und warum bist du
nicht am mikrofon 2 wo ich gesagt hab ja
hier geht es leitungen die muss ein
bisschen rau beachten dass es quasi auch
eine quotierte regel ist
deswegen hat war ja der vorschlag auf
der einen seite die männer auf der
anderen seite die frauen also ist ein
mikrofon 1 dann und janin wissler geht
dann auch für hin damit sie danach dann
sprechen kann ricoh ich freue mich auf
seinem redebeitrag der danke mikrofon
doch noch gefunden
ich darf von den genossinnen und
genossen zu hause einen großen bunten
entnehmen dass wir nachdem wir wenn wir
diesen parteitag beendet haben
gut gestärkt und mit einer stimme
rausgehen
das betrifft auch das thema offene
grenzen und wir haben gestern einen
beschluss gefasst mit dem leitantrag wo
dieses thema für mich klar und deutlich
beantwortet das
[Applaus]
meine große bitte ist dass damit die
diskussion über zeitungsartikel über
interviews in den medien aufhört dass
wir die debatten dort führen wo sie
hingehören auf parteitagen in grieben
hier noch mitgliederversammlung aber
nicht öffentlich über die presse
[Applaus]
ich bin in der kommunalpolitik aktiv bin
kreisvorsitzender meine des
kreisverbandes wenn wir kompromisse
finden
und wenn ich mich in die debatten
engagiert in er gescheit kämpfer für
meine position
aber eins ist immer klar wenn ich dann
wenn wir einen kompromiss gefunden haben
wenn es mehrheiten gab dann ist das
unser kompromiss denn streiten wir dafür
und setzten ihn möglichst durch und
darum bitte ich alle beteiligten und das
was wir in den letzten wochen und
monaten in der öffentlichkeit an bilder
abgegeben haben
das ist es was uns mehr schadet als
manche meinung über einzelne position
wir müssen das heute klären deshalb
freue ich mich dass wir diese aussprache
haben
und bitte unsere fraktionsvorsitzende
mit ihren talenten die sie unzweifelhaft
hat das rhetorische das brillante auch
in vielen positionen dafür zu nutzen
dass die sachen die wir gemeinsam
verabredet haben eine starke stimme in
dieser gesellschaft finden und dass ihr
diese themen voranbringen und dass wir
klar gemeinsam wahrnehmbar sind darum
bitte ich euch und wir führen jetzt die
debatte und danach gehen wir gemeinsam
raus vielen dank
[Applaus]
ganz herzlichen dank jacqueline astrid
und danach spricht alexander neu ja
liebe genossinnen liebe genossen ganz im
sinne unseres grundverständnis nämlich
der solidarität sollten wir auch auf den
oman umgang miteinander achten und ich
denke und da oben stets gemeinsam mehr
werden gerechtigkeit es machbar
sollten wir auch eine debatte
miteinander führen die solidarisch ist
wir sollten das was wir predigen nicht
nur von oben und den leuten erzählen
sondern auch gemeinsam leben und ich
denke es ist an der zeit gerade für
unsere fraktions und parteivorsitzenden
denn auch diese gemeinsamkeiten nach
außen zu stellen auf ein weiterhin
hoffentlich dann auch solidarischen
bundesparteitag sitzt für die linke
genauso
der nächste redner der ebenfalls
mitglied der bundestagsfraktion ist
alexander neue von einst dann susanne
heraus ja sogar die genossinnen und
genossen
ich bin etwas überrascht über die
aggressivität mit der plötzlich auch die
rede von sacher bank nicht reagiert
wurde gestern
gestern eine rede von katja kipping hat
sie zwei mal die aussage tätigt die
linke stünde links von der cdu
das phantom skandalös wir stehen nicht
links von der cdu seien links von grüne
und spd und cdu wir haben keinerlei
schnittmengen mit diesen beiden
liberalen parteien die sowohl agenda
2010 als auch kriege zu verursachen
haben und da hätte ich mir einen
aufschrei gewünscht und der ist leider
ausgeblieben
liebe breitenbach wie viele flüchtlinge
sind eigentlich in berlin abgeschoben
worden letzten drei jahren die zahl von
über 1000 gehört wo ist der aufschrei
dagegen die vernehme ich nicht katja
kipping hat im september beim diw eine
rede gehalten wo sie davon sprach dass
menschen nach deutschland kommen sich
ein jahr bewähren müssen und da müssten
sie auch wieder gehen wenn sie das nicht
können soziale ankerpunkte wurde das
genannt wo ist der aufschrei geblieben
ich habe ich nicht gehört
insofern sind hier ist sehr schwierig
immer auf eine person auf die
beliebteste politikerin in der partei so
einzuhalten und mehr zum thema
fluchtursachen spreche heißt dass
ursachen und ursachen bekämpfen und
davon höre ich von denen nichts hier die
ständig diese migrationsfrage und
flüchtlingsfrage aufmachen als eine
moralische frage wir müssen an die
ursachen ran
es sind 900 millionen menschen die
jährlich 65 millionen menschen die
flüchten dafür müssen wir zentrale
antworten geben und das ist keine
migrations feindliche antwort wenn wir
darauf sagen dass der kapitalismus und
das kriege die hauptursachen sind neben
klima fragt die hauptursachen für die
flucht da müssen wir antworten vermissen
die einzige partei im deutschen
bundestag die das tut danke alexander
neue sitzt in der bundestagsfraktion für
die linke
ja denn bislang ist die nächste rednerin
sie ist ja gerade gestern als
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende
wiedergewählt worden
liebe genossinnen und genossen wir haben
gestern mit überwältigender mehrheit
einen leitantrag beschlossen
wir haben positionen festgelegt und wir
haben gesehen dass der konsens in dieser
partei so großes und natürlich ist die
linke die partei die an der seite der
schwachen steht und dabei machen wir
keinen unterschied zwischen herkunft
sexueller orientierung oder geschlecht
wir stehen auf der seite der schwachen
und wir stehen an der seite der
beschäftigten wenn sie um ihre
arbeitsplätze kämpfen
wir stehen an der seite der
hartz-iv-betroffenen wenn sie sich
wehren und natürlich und da dürfen wir
doch und erreichen wir als partei keinen
millimeter zurück stehen wir an der
seite von geflüchteten von den menschen
die von abschiebung betroffen sind und
ich bin froh dass die linke im deutschen
bundestag jeder asyl aids verschärfung
nicht zugestimmt hat wir sind die
opposition gegen diese asylrechts
verschärfungen
wir diskutieren auf diesen parteitagen
wir streiten auch und ja es muss auch
mal sein
aber wir sollten das solidarisch tun und
wir sollten das kulturvoll tun
und das allerwichtigste ist dass wir
streiten uns jetzt aber wenn wir diese
halle verlassen wenn wir rausgehen sind
wir eine partei und dann nehmen wir den
politischen gegner wieder ins visier und
kämpfen gegen die gesellschaftlichen
missstände
die gesellschaftlichen missstände sind
so kurz und unsere aufgabe als linke ist
so groß dass wir uns selbst beschäftigen
nicht leisten können
wir tragen nicht nur verantwortung für
uns sondern für millionen von menschen
die uns bei der bundestagswahl ihre
stimme gegeben haben
für die denn wohl der hoffnung und die
dürfen wir nicht enttäuschen und ein
letztes
wir haben wir stehen zwei landtagswahlen
an in bayern und bei uns in hessen und
unser gegner in hessen heißt volker
bouffier und diese rechte cdu und unser
gegner heißt hfc weil wir alles dafür
tun wollen den einzug zu verhindern
und ich möchte einen tollen wahlkampf
machen und ich möchte wahlkampf machen
mit katja kipping und mit sahra
wagenknecht und mit bernd riexinger
unter dietmar schweigler brauchen
die linke ist eine errungenschaft
besitzern errungenschaft dass wir es
geschafft haben vor über zehn jahren
diese partei zu gründen aus wie 14 und
pds und wir sind seitdem noch viel mehr
geworden dafür von neumitgliedern das
ist unsere verantwortung und deshalb
lasst uns heute streiten aber lasst uns
danach rausgehen und das muss klar sein
wie unser gegner ist der politische
gegner und diese gesellschaftlichen
verhältnisse die wir verändern
danke landtagswahlen und dann wissler
ist dort auch die spitzenkandidatin
bürger führen will man am mikrofon 2
susanne herausstrich danach ein mikrofon
1 und ein mikrofon zwei bereitet sich
dann vor hubert krüger und ein mikrofon
1 elke altmann liebe genossinnen und
genossen janine ich kann jedem satz von
dem den du gerade gesagt hast eins zu
eins unterschreiben
und ich glaube da sind wir genau bei dem
was ich als erwartungshaltung als ich
habe es ja nicht so weit ist ein heim
parteitag mitgebracht habe auch als
aufforderung von unseren genossinnen und
genossen tatsächlich ein bild das das 1
1 das was uns verbindet und wenn ich den
parteitag bis zu der rede heute und
insbesondere den nachfragen verfolgt
habe gibt es 95 prozent einigkeit in
verschiedenen fragen es gibt zwei drei
punkte wo wir unterschiedlicher meinung
sind
lasst uns diese aber sachlich und fair
miteinander austragen
das ist das erste weil ich glaube
zwischenrufe berufe oder das verächtlich
machen einer anderen meinung dass sollen
bitte schön die bürgerlichen parteien
machen dafür ist unterliegen keinen
platz
[Musik]
und liebe genossinnen und genossen ich
bin auch hier zum leipziger parteitag
gekommen um klare antworten zu geben
spanien hat gesagt wir haben noch zwei
landtagswahl eine nahe zukunft vor uns
in hessen und bayern
ich hätte mir antworten auf die
anstehenden fragen gewünscht und wir
haben jetzt eine diskussion festgemacht
am bericht der arbeit der
bundestagsfraktion der ich ja seit
kurzem auch angehören darf und wenn ich
die debatten dort verfolgt habe haben
wir uns in verschiedenen situationen zu
sachfragen immer versucht fährt zu
einigen was nicht funktioniert ist dass
man mit persönlichen unterstellungen das
hat auch in der rede von dietmar gestern
eine rolle gespielt das bringt uns nicht
weiter
liebe genossinnen und genossen die wir
vorsitzende der partei aber auch liebe
vorsitzender fraktionen ich halte es
auch als grundschullehrer gesagt wenn
ich viertklässlern beibringen kann dass
man sich zusammenraufen kann ein gutes
team sein kann und gute gemeinsame
arbeit leisten kann muss uns das als
partei doch auch möglich sein bitte
bitte gebt euer bestes die sonne heraus
ist jetzt die nächste hier in dieser
begrenzung als stadtverordneter in 101
und elke altmann die bitte zum mikrofon
1 vielen dank mein name ist susanne
heraus ich bin kreissprecherin in
wuppertal mit der deligierten nummer 202
ich komme darauf zurück ich bin eine
kleine kreissprecherin
ich bin eine kleine stadtverordneten die
kleine überzeugte kommunalpolitikerin
und was heute hier passiert gegen unsere
fraktionsvorsitzende des empört mich da
bin ich zutiefst traurig drüber
wir in zehn jahren arbeit in wuppertal
auf den straßen gemacht haben und mit
sarah da hat kommt nach wuppertal wenn
ich sie wenn wir sie rufen sie immer für
die genossinnen und genossen da steht
für jede frage zur antwort und ich frage
mich wer das ja initiiert hat und ich
verurteile das auf schaffte und ich
hoffe und ich hoffe wirklich und ich
hoffe wirklich dass nadine zu dem
solidarischen grundwert zurückkommen
konnten wir seit zwei tagen sprechen
von denen habe ich nur gemerkt bis zur
reederei sarahs eine fantastische rede
ist sie hat alle mitgenommen
wir haben alle geklatscht und dann
plötzlich brach es um ich frage mich wer
war das aus welchem zweck und passiert
das gerade wir bedienen gerade wir
bedienen hier gerade die presse wir sind
wir sind eine linke partei
verdammt noch mal begreift dass vielen
dank
ein mikrofon ein mikrofon 2 spricht
robert krüger danach spricht ein
mikrofon 1 elke altmann und fabio de
masi geht bitte schon zum mikrofon 2 ich
muss meiner vorrednerin in einem sehr
wichtigen punkt widersprechen nicht wir
alle haben geklatscht bei der rede von
sarah ganz besonders habe ich nicht
klatschen können als sarah wieder einmal
dieses falsche optionale zwischen den
offenen grenzen hier für die menschen in
not gegen der hilfe vor ort für die
hungernden ausgespielt hat wir kennen es
aus der sozialpolitik wir müssen nicht
die eigenen schwachen gegen die anderen
ausspielen
wir können das eine tun ohne das andere
zu lassen wir können vor ort helfen und
die leute die sich auf den bisher
befinden klar einlassen und im hier ein
sicheres obdach bieten danke liebe
genossinnen und genossen
[Applaus]
danke danke hubert es erhält das wort
elke altmann danach habe der nase und
ein mikrofon 1 bereitet sich bitte
danach vor am ihrer mohammed ali mein
name slk altmann mit der delegierten
nummer 006 aus dem kreisverband bautzen
in der oberlausitz
ich habe meinen rede zettel mit dem
thema versehen diskussionskultur und
dazu muss ich gar nicht mehr sagen als
das was die janine von gesagt hat ich
stimme dir dort in allem zu du hast mir
voll aus dem herzen gesprochen
ja und mehr muss ich nicht mehr sagen
genau das sollten wir tun wir sollten
uns nicht gegenseitig zerlegen soll
sondern wir sollten nach dem motto
unseres parteitags gemeinsam mehr werden
[Applaus]
danke ich möchte für das präsidium vor
allem für die redezeit disziplin von
euch danken fabi de masi hat jetzt das
wort danach ein mikrofon 1 amira
mohammed ali und tillmann losgeht bitte
schon los zum mikrofon zwei familie mal
liebe genossen in aktion
ich möchte mich zunächst entschuldigen
und zwar bei den pflegekräften bei den
taxifahrern bei den leiharbeitern die
vielleicht hier zu schauen und die sich
fragen ob es überhaupt noch auf diesem
parteitag um ihre interessen geht
und zwar ganz gleich welcher herkunft
und wir haben wir haben in dieser partei
eine kontroverse debatte geführt
aber ich möchte euch erinnern katja
kipping vertritt seit 13 jahren das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen
ich vertrete es nicht aber es völlig
legitim dass sie das tut
wir streiten darüber aber niemand stellt
sich hin und versucht ein tribunal über
sie zu errichten
und ich möchte noch etwas sagen
katja hat die frage offener grenzen für
alle so bezeichnet sie hat gesagt es
ginge nicht um eine realistische
forderungen sondern um eine frage der
haltung
das ist legitim aber eine frage der
haltung die die partei spaltet die hilft
keinem einzigen ertrinkender flüchtlinge
im mittelmeer lieber genosse und
genossen gregor gysi hat die frage der
offenen grenzen falle so bezeichnet er
verstünde darunter reisefreiheit ja ich
würde mir eine welt wünschen in der die
menschen nach deutschland kommen auch
bei schlechtem wetter weil sie reisen
wollen wenn wir diese probleme gelöst
haben dann müssen wir doch über diese
frage überhaupt nicht mehr streiten weil
die menschen am liebsten dort bleiben wo
sie ihre sozialen beziehungen haben
liebe genossinnen und genossen und all
jene die meinen ein börnig senders 1
scherrer mikroben eine sahra wagenknecht
ein harri grünberg der sohn von
holocaust-überlebenden der genau
dieselbe position vertritt oder ich als
enkel eines italienischen
widerstandskämpfers wir seien
gleichzusetzen mit acht die hand zu nah
an der wand geschaukelt liebe
genossinnen und genossen
und deswegen last und auf die
gemeinsamkeit übersetzt lasst uns diesen
kindergarten sein und lieber elke sarah
hat hiergegen keinen beschluss verstoßen
denn unser beschluss lautet oft
begrenzen
für menschen in not oder für alle
menschen das ist die streitfrage die wir
hier gar nicht geregelt haben sonst
hätte man es rein schreiben müssen
es ist aber auch nicht sinnvoll sie hier
zu regeln weil wir jetzt uns um die
menschen kümmern müssen die im
mittelmeer ersaufen und deswegen hört
auf mit diesen quatsch liebe freundinnen
und freunde
[Applaus]